[Music]
so good morning everyone thank you so
much for coming
my name is John Zimmerman I'm a
researcher in the rice group at MSR and
it's my pleasure to introduce Angie as
Sarah was a full professor at Southern
University in Germany and he was
actually my PhD advisor so I'm really
looking forward to the talk
Angiers is one of the top people in soft
engine research he is an ACM fellow he
won several most influential paper
Awards for his work on - thank you -
thank you very much I was making jokes
because I became a same fellow for our
work - offer posit or ease among others
okay so that yes that's great
it's always nice to come back in to the
Seattle area just noted that it's now 18
years ago since I came here the first
time and it's amazing how much things
have changed since then so I was
strolling through the city yesterday and
I found that the Alaskan Highway is now
ripe for demolition which people were
talking about 18 years ago it's nice to
see the nan the new 520 bridge now in
operation which people were talking
about eighteen years ago and and and and
I and and and and I understand that in
only seven years there will be an
extension to Microsoft so before I
retire I will see all the other
beautiful things that people have been
talking about all these years the place
where I come from so this is this is
Germany over here and this little pixel
- 2 x 2 pixel thing here there's the
state of salon and this is a city of
sbrick and well I also read there 16
years ago and we've had no new bridges
or no new what we got on we got a new
light rail yes but it has two new
stations - very much like the one over
here betim and the place actually but um
but things don't change that much it's
fine and it's good because things are
good as they are although there is one
particular point where things do change
and if you haven't been to sbrick and
for some time this is our newest
building in computer science this is our
oh I think it should be our tenth
building or so that we're getting there
this is an all new this is an all new
Center for IT security and earlier this
year it has been announced that this
Center is going to be expanded massively
but now there's about 100 researchers in
there it's going to expand to 500
researchers in the course of the next 10
years so meaning that right now we are
having one application talk every week
and is going to remain that way for the
next 10 years which is fun so if you
have any friend who for some reason
doesn't like to go to Microsoft Research
which is also what I recommend to my
students and who likes work in security
ask them to check us out it's a it's a
very dynamic place to be in and what I'm
doing there is among others the work
that I'm presenting today this is mining
input grammars for security testing
although this is a bit well this is not
the best title for this talk as I
realized unfortunately only yesterday
because a much better title for this
talk would be something like making
$50,000 a month by fuzzing software and
now that I have your attention the money
is a great motivator and let me tell you
let me tell let me tell you how we're
doing this so fuzzing is what most of
you know I very much suppose is the idea
of feeding programs with random input at
the system level this is what Miller who
invented the term and the technique in
1989 and the paper today is a classic an
empirical study on the reliability of
UNIX utilities where Barton and his
students went along and created random
inputs fed them into the UNIX utilities
at the time and saw the crashing and
hang
and actually a very wide number 25 to 33
percent of them because they were never
ever subject to such inputs before
actually crashed and hanged this is a
typical output of a father it's very
easy to build a father actually that's
five lines of Python code which will
happily produce code which will happily
produce inputs like these I'm sure there
is a programming language where this is
actually a valid program yeah what
exactly sure maybe we should maybe we
can fit this into a Perl interpreter of
sorts or something else but thing is the
thing is there will be lines in there
which simply are very long so so
programs are prone to buffer overflows
anything that parses things will check
for say for Strings for beginning of a
string end of a string so meant there's
many ways that programs can fail simply
by scanning this input and at the time
yes plenty of plenty of different
utilities on the various UNIX flavours
of the time on sun on Solaris and IBM
and so on all happily failed actually
the nice exception to the rule was the
glue tools which already existed a ton
they turned out to be the most robust
ones and this is also this is also the
base for the tools we have in today on
Linux and since then of course at 1989
has been a long time anyone now knows
how to fuzz a program reliability is
much improved and today is actually
pretty hard to get any of these systems
to crash if you use the same technique
as Bart Miller did in 1989 but some
thing has that parsers that we have
today that are written today are much
more robust and then the parses we had
in 1989 where people only began to
imagine that there could be some weird
input that feeds into ones program the
problem is that a well-written parser
will happily reject all invalid input as
invalid and you will never ever reach
the code that actually matters to you
namely the runtime system the deeper
layers that can be
the powers away you would like to find
we would like to find bugs or whether
you'd like to find successes however if
you do have a syntactically valid input
that is an input that is actually
processed by the parser then you have a
chance to discover bugs in those later
stages that happen that are that then
process the input as parsed by the
parser and that's and in order to get
such a syntactically valid input there's
well what we need is a description of
what makes a valid input this is called
the input language of a program and we
know although there's language theory
for that and what we can do is we can
create a grammar that describes the
input structure the syntactic rules of
the input and using this grammar we can
then produce syntactically correct input
this is something we did a student of
mine in 2012
now that's five years ago and my student
Christian Haller built this whole thing
for JavaScript he built a JavaScript
grammar which actually was quite some
work writing this down and using this
JavaScript grammar which he created his
tool would then happily
create inputs that are indeed valid
JavaScript and feed these to JavaScript
parsers such as the one that is found in
Firefox or in Chrome and this input as
you see it over here was one of the
first inputs that actually crashed the
parser or that crash the JavaScript
interpreter which actually is a serious
thing because if you can manage to crash
an interpreter or the JavaScript
interpreter this typically is the base
for later exploit and if you can if you
have an exploit in the JavaScript
interpreter that's very serious because
this means that you can take over the
entire browser and then and then collect
arbitrary data from from the user
browses today
like operating system so we get full
control of everything the interesting
thing about the work of Christian this
father was that it not only would not
only would it produce arbitrary random
inputs it would all you could also used
the very same parser to parse existing
JavaScript or programs of which there
were many and to top it all off he used
his parser to parse existing JavaScript
programs from bug reports which were
known to have caused troubles before and
he used them to parse them and then to
recombine them so in a way he was
looking at reports of say the measles
and cholera parts these to recombine
them and created new strains that would
then hand and feed then feed her feed
all of these to the interpreter in
horror in order in in the hope of
triggering new bugs which was lots of
fun it also was very successful over the
course of nine months he got 18 chromium
security awards 12 Mozilla bug bounty
awards from Google and Mozilla
respectively and more specifically he
gained $50,000 in bug bounties in the
first four weeks of running his tool
running his tool on a single machine or
a laptop so we're not even talking about
a server farm or anything this is him
this is Christian after these four weeks
after pay so he get to the top of all
the security of all the security
leaderboards and everything so that was
that was fun he got hired he got get
hired away by Mozilla at a quite nice
salary it's not fifty thousand dollars a
month but it's steady it's fine and his
job description was simply to attempted
to continue to run his tool bed was done
and and that's what is so so he's
running his tool for five years now he's
perfecting it he's in in these five
years
so no sorry since well there's one year
ago and so since Wi-Fi one what
one year ago when Alistair I will just
ask him his tool had found four thousand
bugs had found four thousand bugs in the
JavaScript interpreters of firefox and
chrome
all of these bugs confirmed by
developers fixed so all the shebang
others there and by the way he zips by
the way while for Mozilla he'd so
Mozilla gave him the or give him the
authorization to still run his tool on
Chrome and we still get back bounties
once in a while as a side business so he
gets the steady income from Mozilla and
he gets the back bodies from chrome so
he's he he's a he's perfectly at ease
yes this is buffer overruns this is all
sorts over this is all sorts of ways to
all sorts of ways to cause the inter
interpreter to hang or to crash so its
buffer overruns it's it's bugs in the
optimization stages and the just-in-time
compiler everything and as I said most
of the the largest success comes from
the fact that his tool is able to parse
existing bug reports and existing inputs
and recombine them so not only are his
inputs not completely random but
actually Martin but a bug actually
there's a stronger resemblance to
existing code that's one thing and the
second thing is that if you search in
the vicinity of existing bugs you're
likely to find more bugs because some as
we know bug fixes well aren't always
perfect
sometimes they treat more the symptom
than the cause and if you search in the
vicinity you're going to find more this
is what MIT is so particularly
successful if if I'm running or if I'm
drivin when when a taxi driver or like
asks me so what I what do we do for a
living
meaning that I'm a professor also you so
so so you're running from my text
players money and everything so have you
already done some things that actually
have have you done something where you
can pay things back okay you had
Microsoft get asked this all the time
but but for me this is rather rare then
I then I can ask this a taxi driver so
which browser I using
oh I'm using Firefox and Ali yes you
know it's because of my see the fact
that you can use Firefox and it's all
safe is well to some extent part just
quite some extent actually due to our
work with my student at the time and
then he's very happy and everything is
settled so this is work there's already
a couple of years ago it was very nice
we loved it all set a nice using paper
out of it but one thing that so in
principle one could do this for every
program but the problem is that well you
need a grammar in the first place and
creating such a grammar for a for a
non-trivial input and most inputs are
non-trivial it's actually quite some
work for Christian took in three months
to create this JavaScript grammar and if
you want to and actually if you want to
have a real working grammar for C
programs for instance just in order to
do some refactoring work or like things
which is such that you have a good
parser for it there's actually something
quite expensive I think you have to
shell out about ten thousand dollars for
a single license for a for a super C for
a good C grammar for instance yes a
really good grammar you just need a good
enough grammar so you could write a
grammar that is much more permissive
than it needs to be and rely on the real
parsers to some extend yes if you want
to if you want to have a grammar this
simply produces lots of JavaScript code
you can deal with a grammar that is you
can deal with a grammar that only deals
with a subset of JavaScript for instance
but if you want the very same grammar
also to parse existing inputs and to
recombine them it really needs to go
down to the tune to the tiniest details
in order to be able to process all these
that's right that's right if your that's
right if your yeah so so there's two
things in here so your grammar may unmai
over approximate that is them it may
produce more inputs that may produce
inputs are actually not valid JavaScript
then in this particular setting of
fuzzing well you're going to live with
whatever 20% 50% of inputs
that will simply be rejected so that's
other is you're just wasting a bit of
time but if you have a grammar that is
the under approximates you're going to
miss out a couple of features which will
not be tested and then you will miss out
the bugs that are in there so that's the
let's sit down set up the whole thing so
there's these two sides but then we're
talking about con then are we talking
about context-free grammars here anyway
and JavaScript has plenty of
context-sensitive features as any
programming language so actually
cristinaw said to do a couple of tricks
in order to deal with identifiers and
others in order to in order to in order
to in order to have the parser accept
more inputs um so what we wanted to what
we we started to reason about was the at
the time was the idea of whether it
would be possible to learn such grammars
given not only a set of samples that's
there's a couple of works that do that
using machine learning but actually
using the program at hand that processes
those inputs in order to learn what its
inputs or what if how its inputs are
structured and the way we built it is as
follows we do have a set of inputs which
can be a very small set actually we're
aiming to get this set to be the empty
set we feed these inputs to a program we
observe how the program processes these
inputs we do this dynamically rev a tool
called Auto Graham which observes how
the program processes those inputs and
out of these observations it produces a
grammar this grammar can then be fed
into a phaser which then happily will
create more inputs towards the program
thus creating in the end a virtuous
circle where you learn more and more
about a way to learn more and more about
the grammar and the program itself so
how does this work
um think of a program that processes a
very simple input they say you are elves
we all know what your rels are made of
and the idea is as follows I
jor-el is made out of different parts we
do have a protocol we do have the
hostname we do have a port we do have a
login people you should not use logins
in URLs because they're transmitted in
the clear but well they provide this and
and there's also path so these are
standard elements and we do have a
couple of separators in there and all of
these elements while they're being
processed by the program that processes
a URL all of these individual fragments
go through different paths in the
execution so the protocol for instance
the protocol is being used to determine
what is going to be parsed how how the
rest is going to be parsed the hostname
is going to end up in some is going to
end up in some DNS resolver function
that is going to return us an IP address
to which we are going to connect using
the given port and then over that
connection we're going to send out the
log in as well as the page request and
all of these saw all of these data all
these individual fragments go through
different paths through the execution
and they end up in different functions
and this idea that there is a natural
separation of concerns in the program
execution that corresponds to the
structure in the input is what we want
to exploit so all of these different
functions for each fragment different
functions that are stored in different
variables this is the feature this is
the basic idea where what we we want to
be able to extract the structure of the
grammar so how can we do that
essentially we have explored two ways
one very thorough one and one very
simple one the first technique is that
we looked at is to use dynamic painting
which essentially dynamically during
execution attaches a label a tag to
individual in to individual data as
elements as they're being processed and
this tag propagates along the
computation so for instance and
Tagg in our case labels all the inputs
with their origin that is the input
source and the position in the input so
for instance we can track where the port
goes to and even if the port gets
converted to a number the number
inherits the tag of the string and the
port then carries that tag over to the
function so we can we can track all of
these we can check all of these inputs
down the second technique is much
simpler this simply consists of going of
taking a memory dump at a particular
point in time and simply looking for all
string variables whether any of these
string variables contains some
characters that happen that also
happened to occur in the original input
this is much simpler it's much cruder
there's also room for error in there but
it turns out that the latter one is
something that one can implement that
one can actually implement much easier
than the first one and I had some fun a
couple of weeks ago implementing the
second technique in Python in Python
tracking a variable is very checking so
in Python accessing memory during
execution is a very simple exercise you
I do have a function that is called set
trace and you pass this sit and here I
have this API call set trace and you
pass it a function which is called trace
it and this trace it function is going
to be called for every single line that
is executed and every with every line
what you get past the current frame the
current event meaning that a new line
has been executed as well as other
information and in the current frame you
can then look up all the local variables
and all of their values as Python
elements it's very simple so actually
writing a debugger in Python is twelve
lines of code okay so compare that to
Java or ah see it's no fun at all in
Python dynamic analysis is is a breeze
and what we do is we access all the
local variables we access all of their
values
then we simply check for the values if
it's a strain and if it hasn't if I say
if it has two characters or more and if
this value also occurs in the input that
we've seen then we simply store the
variable that we have sort of variable
and the value that we have just seems we
just track these and let me show you how
this works in a real code so here's the
very same code again I do have a
function which is your L parse I do have
a couple of inputs which are passed to
them and very down here
I should have precisely the function
that we have just seen so I'm using this
trace function thing where is it again
so one second here we go this is the set
tracing function I am producing some
output and for every value I'm saving it
I'm accessing the individual their
variables and I'm saving those that are
also occur in the input now if I run
this on URL parse this is precisely what
I get so I get the during URL parse a
function which I have not implemented
which I've never seen actually this
would be something I've never looked
into that there's a variable called URL
which holds the path this is one part of
the input there's a variable named
fragment which lo and behold it's the
fragment there's a variable called
scheme which happens to be the scheme
there's a variable called net lock which
holds the host and the port which is
precisely what we have over here and
there's a path which very much like the
URL also holds this very path over here
and I can now go and also apply this to
other inputs just for the fun of it
where are we and let me make this the
first input so here I'm happy lacking
along so here's another URL and here we
also have a scheme which now is HTTPS
and we do have a net lock again the
location which also occurs in here so
you can see that simply by looking at
the variables I can already extract the
individual lexical items as they occur
as they occur in in the input so from
this I can now go and infant use this
and use this knowledge that the input is
decomposed into these variables to
derive a grammar namely in two steps I
start with a very simple grammar that
simply says my grammar consists of
precisely this input this is very
trivial anybody can write a grammar like
this and then you create a disjunction
of a multiple inferred from there so
very simple it's not how you do it okay
well and then and what we do then yeah
sure you know grammar inference can be a
very easy thing it's actually 100
percent sound so it's cool every every
every string in that grammar is a valid
input so and then what I do is I go and
for each and every variable I see I
introduce a rule by replacing all the
occurrences of that value by a in by a
non-terminal
and then I say this non-terminal expands
to the appropriate value let's try that
out with the values that we've just seen
so here's my initial grammar here we go
and now I apply the second rule I go and
for all of these variables I introduce
appropriate new rules so let's start
with net lock for instance net lock this
is this one so I'm going to replace this
string as it occurs up here by the net
lock thing so this is what I get so now
I have this expansion to net lock and I
have let's see what net lock is in here
I can do the same for the scheme I can
repeat the same thing for the path for
the fragment as well as finally for this
URL variable which doesn't really belong
here I guess it's some sort of misnomer
but that's what you get and if I do this
again then I see that the path is in
fact a URL and the URL is path all these
all these names are well chosen except
for the euro l1 I have no idea what the
what the Fox in the URL parts thought of
when they gave this variable this name
but what you can see here now is how we
have decomposed this grammar input into
into a nicer things so our URL starts
with a scheme
followed by location followed by a path
followed by a fragment now if I know
this is just for one single input okay
and of course I want to extend this to
multiple inputs yes yes I'll come to
that in a second wait whoa wait a moment
will will gradually expand this whole
thing okay
so this is just for one single input and
this is just one decomposition the one
decomposition we've seen for that input
now the idea is that I can go and do
this for multiple inputs sorry and for
multiple inputs what I'm going to so I
actually have implemented this whole
thing so here we go
and if we implement this in forum this
is precisely the grammar that we get so
this is just live here in Python note
that this is a fully self-contained
Python program and we are at line 200
here so this is its took me four hours
to build it to design it to build it and
to quality control it so that was a that
was something that was not very hard to
do and this was very annoying from a
student who had spent a year building
this whole thing for Java but his work
is much more sophisticated and the very
crude thing I'm having over here now the
interesting thing is that I can repeat
this saying for multiple inputs and I
can easily merge these grammars together
and since I have the structure I can
merge them by rule so for every single
rule that I have I'm simply going to add
a disjunction for the next value that I
see which actually represents the
individual variables the individual
values that the respective variable can
take so if I do that and I'm going to
spare you the code for go code for that
this is not this is not very nice code
but I'm simply going to run that so what
I have done now here is I have taken
three inputs with different schemes for
instance in Howey see here's a
disjunction
it's HTTP or HTTPS
and the fragment variable wants his ref
and once his ref - and the host of
course can take different values and the
query we have no other query this is one
of the inputs well there's only there's
just one variable yes so we have a path
that can take the value that has taken
the value / path and slash bar and over
here we see the we see the various
schemes that there are so we see that
there can be something you can't you can
have something with a fragment you can
have something without a fragment you
can have something with a query and a
fragment so these are different
expansions and if I would add now some
syntactic sugar I could go and say that
the query in here and the fragment are
actually actually actually both optional
now if I have such a grammar and indeed
I can start with this very grammar I can
immediately use this for producing for
producing various combinations which
then leaves it which gives us various
combinations of the illiberal
constituents and then I can create
arbitrary combinations of hosts and
paths and references and for some reason
no query and you're good I'm going to
query the query area has expanded let's
try that again
do we see a query no query how come good
here we go again
another combination so every time I can
use this roll of dice use an arbitrary
expansion writing a producer for a given
grammar again this is eight lines of
code not very complicated okay and of
course the more elaborated my grammar
gets the more alternatives I have and
the more possibilities for combination
echo combination follow so as I said
this is a very simple program we use
these programs for teaching I'm having a
course on security testing the next one
starts mid-october and we are indeed
showing folks how to create such
grammars and how to mind such grammars
this is a very program we're giving out
to students such that they can then try
out and see how it works now this is
just the
this is just a very simple version okay
there's still lots and lots of pieces
missing but it's clear how he can it's
clear that there's ways to further
expand this and mm-hmm
we now get to our well a real
implementation the one that my student
took a year for this is now for a real
programming language so we're working
with Java I never tried to submit the
program where I'm saying and I never
tried to submit a paper where I'm saying
this works beautifully on this 20 lines
on this or this ten lines of Python for
some reason has to be this big Java
program or this big C program so I'm
always fearing that if I submit
something that works on Python people
won't take it seriously so we built this
whole thing for Java and it has a full
study grammar inference for Java
programs this is actually the first
technique ever that is able to mine
input grammars from programs what we did
have before was mining study grammars
from samples which is very nice Google
at Google has implemented quite a number
of machine learning techniques that tell
you that if in a PDF to command you have
this token and this other token then
typically this next talk is going to
follow and you can create valid
documents with that the problem though
is that this is not going to tell you
well it's only going to give you those
documents that look realistic but it's
not going to give you documents that
explore that explore all the other
possibilities there are in the program
which is why Google does that yes I
don't don't you don't know whether they
have a paper but I spoke to a spoke to
do my gobo bridge at Google I was not
under NDA and he told me that and
there's this work with Patrice good from
yes machine learning for fuzzing yes
sure so you have the same paper
I think they never bothered to write a
paper about it okay yes I know that work
and also this for those people have
Stanford also this also appeared this
year at PL di where people have where
they have whatever good
great technique for inferring grammars
using some active learning of the
program but our idea is to have the
program as a reference to extract the
grammar for it okay not samples not
nothing as little as possible and so our
java implementation uses dynamic
painting so we don't look into but we
don't will don't look at memory dumps we
simply follow all characters we also do
also do some active learning to check
for repetitions and optional parts that
is for each and every grammar element we
try to we actually go and find out what
happens if we leave that out and if it's
still if this still results in a valid
input if the program under test still
accepts this we know it's optional for
every element we try repetitions and if
it accepts multiple repetitions we know
we can repeat it that's fun too and very
nice too we do have a number of
predefined lexical items such as numbers
and others which we identify so these
are regular expressions and if we find
out that some input matches a regular
expression say H such as a number we try
out more numbers and if we find that
more numbers are also matched we know
that this is a number and we also have a
hierarchy of these and also have a
hierarchy of these expressions so the
next so we have natural numbers and next
coming up is negative numbers and this
is how we find out the de port number
for instance only can be a natural
number but cannot be negative number I
have no idea what happens if you pass a
negative port number whatever is going
to happen I remember that if you kill a
negative process on UNIX if you kill a
process and give it negative process ID
the anti group is going to collapse but
no idea what happens if you open a
negative port but anyway we now know
from our work that pork's cannot be
negative in the URL okay and I'm going
to give you a couple of examples of what
this actually looks like so this is
again our URL example better now with
our Otto Graham prototype applied on the
Java net URL parser and this is the and
this is the grammar and that present and
this is the grammar that pops out of it
this is the raw output of our tool
okay we just as in the Python example
that I shown you before we make use of
actual variable names and function names
in order to make this all very readable
and here you can see what is a URL URL
starts a URL we start with a spec and
there's a string in the beginning and
this string is a protocol followed by an
authority as well as by an optional path
the Authority consists of an optional
password at a host the host is mandatory
followed by an optional port the
protocol in our example here is always
HTTP the user info is a given but the
host is a hostname the port is a
sequence of digits the path is actually
a path the query and references are all
alphanumeric characters with special
characters in there and this is what we
learned from this one single example
only so simply by loops if simply by
looking at this one single example which
now has a couple of features and
generalizing over it and finding out
which parts are optional finding out
which parts can be repeated we get all
the generalizations that we get in this
anti grammar yes so also the protocol is
something we cannot generalize because
our tool has no knowledge about HTTP
protocols if it had knowledge about
protocols then it would then I think it
would be cheating at some point so we
cannot find it so I mean so we can
generalize over individual protocols
what we can find out is that we cannot
generalize protocol to an arbitrary
string because arbitrary strings would
not be accepted but we cannot find out
that other protocols say like HTTP or
file or something would be accepted we
would need extra inputs for that the
reason for that is simple the way the
Java unit and parser works is for a
given protocol if you pass that in it's
going to look whether there's any class
in the class loader that matches the
appropriate name and if there is a class
it's going to load it and then is going
to execute it
and we cannot well we cannot come up
with a neat and and universal mechanism
that at some point would search the file
system for Java files but that makes
specific file names so that's not
something we can do so we don't know
this but the other parts yes the path
the query reference in all of us this
can all be systematically expanded such
that we know which parts are actually
part of the grammar you had a question
not now we're not looking at the control
forum we're only looking at the dataflow
thing is if we look at the control flow
if we look at control at implicit
information flow that would be the
correct term then we would very quickly
get and find out that everything depends
on everything and so we only look at the
dataflow this is a this is a limitation
for instance so this technique works
because we have a very number because
the URL parser is a handwritten parser
if we apply this technique say on the
table driven parser such as a generated
parser we would not be able to find out
that there is information flow along all
this power or along all these table
elements because all of these are
governed by implicit information flow
generally if you have something like
switch and the character and then in
case of that character do that in case
the other character do that you have a
control dependency and this is something
we cannot cover we well we have to find
this something where we still have to
tune which kind of control dependencies
we want to look at in which others we
don't want to look at but there is a
couple of expansions which goes into
that direction on the other hand if you
do have a table driven parser
chances are that you do have a computer
readable grammar in the first place
because that's where these table driven
parsers are typically generated from I
can give you another example and this is
actually a Microsoft one this is any
files this is a Java puzzle for any
files and here you can see so any files
that's key value pairs with an equal
sign
in square brackets the essence is in
here so you have lines it consists of
sections or key followed by an arbitrary
number of blanks followed by a space
followed by an optional value the key is
not optional the value is I didn't know
that that you can have something without
values and all of this is in here and
these lines then are happily are
separated by new lines and they're all
are combined into one single into one
single grammar you can see that this is
a bit convoluted so you can see here is
there's a first line let's first mean
parse so there's a first section and
here again we have this section down
here again that's because of the way
this ne5 parser is written and I should
say it's not very well written it's
looks very much it looks looks like it
looks like a crude looks like a crude
scanner but then the but then these
individual elements that are in the
implementation also reflected in our
grammar again but still with a bit of
manual cleanup this becomes a very
beautiful and here's my yes that's what
we do - yes this is a repetition
recognition if we can find out that
because we find out that the input is
valid if we have no lines if we have one
line and if we have multiple lines and
this is how we can then generalize that
there is a is it a clean start I think
it's a clean start so we can so we can
find out that individual elements can be
repeated arbitrary number of times
likewise here for the spaces and others
and here's my this is my or favorite
this is for Jason so we're having so
this is again one single input so one
single sample suffices this is a
constructed example where we actually
look for various ways of number
formatting because these make up
different parts in the parser and again
we feed this into our autograph
and this is the grammar that comes out
of it and I'm very much in love with
that grammar because it's because it's
almost textbook quality you see what is
adjacent file the JSON file is the value
and the value is either a string or
false or true or an object array or null
or a number a string is something called
a hash which is a bad name but I'm happy
with it
something enclosed in double quotes
false and true are false and true an
object is a string a key value pair
followed by more optional key value
pairs as many as needed option separated
by commas and with the closing
parentheses at the end an array is
similar except that we're using that
we're using a square brackets here now
is a null number is an integer followed
by possible fraction and exponent all of
this is in there and again this is what
a tool produces from one single input
okay and you can there's so many things
you can do with that you can use this
immediately for understanding what the
input is made of because we know over
JSON is okay so we understood so we can
see that this grammar is valid but now
imagine you have some unknown file
format and this is what pops out or you
can immediately you can immediately use
this for fuzzing because you can
immediately create tons and tons of tons
and tons of of valid JSON inputs you can
use this to to compare multiple versions
of a program against each other you take
one JSON parser take another JSON parser
you find out what the difference between
the two grammars is so it gives you
plenty of insights about about how the
input is about what the input looks like
and what you can do with it you had a
question
Allport some identifiers most people
with white space or special white spaces
and the ones that are the ones that are
underlined here alpha num with the
special white space these are our
predefined ones just not just not just
not
the three internal is not this actually
false this is part of the grammar in
here but the ones that are underlined in
here this is true up here integer here
and positive integer these should also
be underlined these are our predefined
ones and there's a we have a paper where
this is described these also come as
part of another grammar where these are
being where all of these are being
defined so we simply recognize that
something and how much is this regular
expression and then we know that that
this for all the positive integers that
we have generated actually holds and
after a couple of I think it's five
trials we after five trials we know well
we've seen it for with received work for
fifty-three for 4704 three more then we
assume it's a positive integer we also
do some Newton iteration other stuff
that's all in the works yes what we do
is for every element in one rule we for
one in individual elements in okay for
individual elements in one rule we try
to omit them and we send we check
whether the input is still valid
let me just check I think we also do
this for larger group so we first do
this for individual elements then for
pairs then for triples and so on it
takes some time so this is Jason into
this jason jason it first is a number of
is number of a couple of minutes but um
well he do it once and then you have it
it so there you go then then all of this
becomes x1 x2 x3 and so on so we cannot
we cannot find these if we cannot find
these out either but even so the simple
fact that so it's not only the names
that make these is readable it's also
the structure that follows from it okay
because you can really see how this so
so if you look at the jason
implementation this structure of the
grammar very nicely represents reflects
the structure of the program that
processes it
and you can obfuscate lots of night no
problem but if you start off with
skating the structure of your program
that processes input at plenty of
programmers who will work with your code
later on will be its dreamily angry at
you so you should come up with me if you
want to really obfuscate things you
should also need to come up with some
mechanism that's really bad you need to
come up with a mechanism that not only
obscures the control flow but actually
do it also obscures all the data flow in
your program so you would have to split
these things into multiple variables but
even so if you say I'm going to store
the first three characters in one
variable in the next two characters
another variable all that's going to
show up is that there's a rule in here
that say that false is composed of two
parts and the first is fil and the
second is se so yeah it's a web so so
right now with the dash there should be
ways of obscuring this but right now
we're rather interestingly bring you
more light into into what's happening
here so these are just three examples of
our of our auto gram tool and yes we do
have a couple of exciting work that's in
Dutch dealing with that so right now we
are reimplemented this whole thing for c
programs and the reason for that is that
we found this that we found that our
technique for tagging java elements and
actually changing the representation is
still something that is very brittle so
whenever we have a new subject and
particular more larger more complex
subjects we typically run into bugs in
the Java interpreter which in the Java
in Java Virtual Machines so we have many
ways of getting the Java Virtual Machine
to crash that's very interesting but it
doesn't help us because we need to build
appropriate workaround so now we're
building this whole thing for C programs
for which we do have nice interpreters
and instrumentation infrastructures that
are way more solid plus there's more
interesting system level utilities at
the C level
think of all the operating system parts
or the daemons the protocols or the data
exchanges all this is written in C so
it's fun
with this active learning we already can
do with a minimum of samples one single
sample is great so we can explore all
the variations but in the long run we
want to do this without any samples at
all so for JSON we have we have for
Jason and how do you say that in a spike
solution we have managed to create a
nice little test generator that is
oriented towards the parsing technique
that is able to systematically generate
all the different variations of JSON
that was nice
and now we're generalizing this towards
more programs so which means that in the
longer run you will be able to take an
arbitrary program feed this into our
technique and out pops the grammar this
is the long term goal we're aiming for
the fuzzing part interestingly has lots
and lots of open issues because you want
to apply you want to apply techniques
from want to apply a couple of tricks on
test generation first is you want to
fuzz towards in order to get a maximum
of code coverage or feature coverage you
want to a simple thing covering all the
production rules okay that's again
that's that's in our Python phaser
that's 13 minutes one one hour of work
and it turns out this has not be done
before but as soon as you to
systematically try out to come up with
all sorts of various production rules
you get a much better coverage of the
program and that's because the grammars
were having here and the functions and
that's because the structure of the
program is reflected in the structure of
the grammars and so if you cover the
structure of the grammar you're also
going to cover the structure of the
program this is a very helpful
integration with symbolic testing
grammars on one side program semantics
on the other side how do you bring these
two together so what we can do and what
say one of my students is working on is
to create local solutions with symbolic
constraint solving at the function level
that is determining how can you reach a
particular probable particular behavior
in the program
so solving those constraints and then
finding out well this variable which I
need to have this particular value down
here in that function in order to
achieve that goal is something that
stems from this element in the grammar
because this is something we have
established earlier isn't with dynamic
tainting so we can find out oh if you
pass a minus 1 down here it's going to
crash we can lift that value back to the
grammar and see well let's put in minus
1 in here maybe the minus 1 will be
rejected by the parser but at least
that's so that's worth a try and in the
end what we want to build is the world's
best fuzzing platform yeah I'm going I'm
competing with the pros here I know that
but but yes we want to build it but we
want to bring all of this together
creating a platform where you throw in a
program where we can infer the in way we
can infer the structure of the input
where we can apply smart test generation
techniques based on the structure of the
input and then cover as many features as
possible in a minimum amount of time and
fortunately I'm not alone with that I do
have a I do have a couple of great
postdocs and peds we do have Rahul Gopi
not from Oregon State University student
of Alex gross who's working was working
with me on who's working with me on all
the creative parts of that Nikolas is
working with Nikolas every cough is
working on trading the fuzzer Matthias
has created the first implementation of
Otto Graham Alexander is working on
integration with symbolic testing and
Buuren is doing all the parties doing
all the work on C programs these days
and these are this is the army of folks
who's helping who is helping with it I'd
actually point out that I wrote the
Python program so yeah you know for for
somebody who increasingly relies on
others to write programs and build stuff
it's a to point out that I also can
write stuff myself so just just just to
point that out just to point that our
German professors can write code to
you're happy to analyze my Python code
for whatever features that
occasionally occasionally I write stuff
okay and in the long run yeah this is
funny I looked at looked at five formats
in Wikipedia there's a page that's
called file former there's a list of
file formats these are all the file
formats that are documented somewhere in
Wikipedia there is about I think it's I
think it's I think it's 1,000 different
file formats all possible three and four
letter combinations file extensions are
all written in there JPEG format you
don't know everything under the Sun dot
CR download no idea what this is
oh it's Google Chrome of course and we
want it to be able to infer those
formats one after the other and then be
able to then be able to fuss them all as
I said this very simple question what is
the input language of a program this is
a very simple question and it's all
fully under researched it's it's a
question that
well that's very fundamental to all
sorts of testing and of course to the
program understanding at least of data
understanding but inferring this
automatically is something that well
address the handful of people have
undertaken in the in the in the last
decade and how can i leverage this input
structure in order to cover understand
prevent particular inputs if you have a
parser force but for particular inputs
then you can say okay I'm going to
here's this legacy program which has a
couple of vulnerabilities I'm going to
restrict its input to only those inputs
that I know that are legal or the other
way around and I know that specific
inputs are the malicious I'm going to
infer a grammar for these I'm going to
explicitly prevent them there you go you
don't even have to eat don't even have
to patch the program for your whatever
for your two year old IOT device which
you which you bought at a cheap price
and which no longer is maintained well
at least you can set up a filter for
that all of this translate also into
better understanding of code because if
you know that this part of code
processes this particular input well you
have a deeper understanding of what's
going on and of course this also gives
you an idea about how to cover specific
behaviors how to understand behaviors
there's hundreds of open issues but it's
very easy to be very very easy to start
doing research if I can write a Python
program that infers a grammar in four
hours you can do so I'm sure you folks
can do so in one hour including learning
Python server so please enjoy please
enjoy it all okay and this gets me to
the end of my talk so what have I shown
I've shown you how to use grammars for
for fuzzing of existing programs
obstacle to that is getting a grammar in
the first place and we have shown you
well both the Python prototype as well
as our autocrine baroque Ram Otto Graham
prototype that is able to infer such
grammars automatically and and the
current work of my students happily
working on work working on extending
this idea in various directions and
there's plenty of research opportunities
around it and all of this can actually
be found on our web page that is devoted
to Otto Graham you also find our most
recent technical report with all the
features on with all the features on
unactive learning there so it was fun to
have was my pleasure to present and I'm
happy to take questions thank you very
much for your attention
yes Chris is human readable file formats
or across the wire binary my experience
writing decoders for these things
they're not thanks free yes you'll have
like you know lengths encoded or yes yes
yes yes I do you have a sense of how
well these type of approaches would work
in trying to handle that where the
you're not gonna the output is not
consciously grammar but yes something
else yes so there's - there's um there's
two important issues in there the first
one is context
as you put it what we know here is
context-free grammars and there's plenty
of and in plenty of data formats there's
actually most reasonable formats there
is some amount of context sensitivity in
there you would normally not want a
context-sensitive grammar to describe
these you can say for instance suppose
you have a checksum for instance okay
you do not want to describe the checksum
using a context-sensitive grammar okay
you can't do that okay but that's not
fun I mean you look at regular
expressions and and say I'm not sure
about that but programmers love regular
expressions and for 100 regular
expressions you have one grammar one
context-free grammar that is and I'm
pretty sure that for 100 context-free
grammars you have one context-sensitive
grammar and then we go up the way to
universal grammars and Turing machines
and whatnot so the further further up
you go the less popular things are and
you don't want to write this with the
context-sensitive grammar so what we're
working on is to extend such
context-free grammars with constraints
that tell you that one particular item
is the result of this particular
operation being applied on being applied
on this other item and these operations
is something that we imagine can
actually be extracted from code because
you can find out that the length that is
being that the length that is being
encoded in here actually comes from code
and it's being checked at this point so
we can extract these as we can extract
these operations and feed them in and
fit and make constraints out of them and
this is how you can then represent
constraints regarding with respect to
checksums and length and a four of these
other container formats and binary
formats um actually it's um actually
ever have ever very nice master thesis
on that where I'm awaiting results soon
which which is specifically geared
towards checksums in inputs the second
thing is that what we need here what you
what you have what you have here is is
actually multiple layers of languages
stacked upon each other like in media
but you have oh like say like the ISO
OSI networking model not sure whether
this is still in textbooks but say you
have a layer way describe things in
terms of bits being processed you have a
layer where think about these as data
packets and then somewhere up there you
have a have the application layer same
thing happens with media containers you
have a representation where you have
individual bits with check sums and
lengths and then you have another
representation where you actually talk
about the context of all these
individual frames that are packaged in
here and our goal is to bring these
together not only and by having multiple
grammars so we can have one grammar for
each layer that is crowded but there's
the concept of so-called conjunctive
grammars which is which is in which is a
mostly theoretical result from language
theory but the idea is that you can take
multiple constraints so you know so the
idea is that not nothing that you not
only have these junctions I told you
this can be I or B but you can also have
conjunctions you can tell this can be a
or b and it also has to fulfill this
other constraint and the idea is that
you can then express that a file has to
fulfill the constraints that happen at
the bit level but also at the
application level and all of these
together you can also have negations in
there actually then you get the boolean
grammar then you can say an input has to
fall for this and this and must not be
this okay and then you can actually
combine things like this is a kind of
input that you'd like to avoid so you
have an explicit blacklist for instance
they so this is something that we have
that we are that where we think of in
the near future will be able to infer
these the problem is production because
right now if you only have disjunctions
production is a very simple thing but as
soon as you have conjunctions you
actually have to go into string
constraint solving at others where you
in the end have to invoke something like
humpy or z3 in order to fulfill those
constraints but again this is this is
classical
this is a classical constraint solving
we have tools for that we know how to do
that so it's not out of the reach so two
answers to two longer answers to it to a
single query short question yes Shawn
will have been properly doing that in
the first place writing any grammar
sorry
some wouldn't have been the proper way
to deal with these things to write a
grammar in the first place rather than
you know distracting well you know well
you know and even for a simple thing as
a URL or I think a grammar can be
difficult because we because if you
write the grammar you start to think
you're such a reason about what kind of
characters can be in the path what is
the range of report can L make the port
can okay what kind of characters are
allowed in a password okay this is the
things that make you think hard okay and
it's important but it's important to
capture these constraints precisely
because these are precisely the things
you want to test okay and by having and
by having an automatic learner or in
this case an active learner that infers
those things for you by running tens of
thousands of experiments you get very
way more information than what you could
ever do through manual testing and
probing and so so even for a symbol is
even for for something where we think we
know how something is composed
formalizing this is action X is
formalizing this is actually is actually
manual actually manual work and if you
think about a former that you do not
know okay and say you say you have some
proprietary data forward I remember I
was working and this was during my
students and I was working with a with
some sort of vector drawing program
which had a proprietary data file format
in which everything was stored so I had
no idea what this looked like so I
loaded this for this file into my text
editor and the first characters in that
file were so you're trying to find out
the innards of a such in such file a
question mark it was an insult I mean
it's like you abandon all hope you enter
here or something like that okay so it's
deficits so now we think about so
somewhere there's a high
disk in which somebody has stored
millions and millions of pictures made
with that particular program on a hard
disk and you have no idea what is NATO
but if we can extract the grammar then
we can maybe if we can extract the
grammar for it then we will be able to
identify what it's made of and actually
if you think of it we can create a
universal XML converter take anything
and convert it to XML using using the
this very structure in the grammar to
produce XML out of it and books all of a
sudden you can reuse everything so yes
there's plenty of plenty of usages for
that people might want to replace their
well if you have a grammar then it's
easier to it's easier to create a parcel
again out of it it's obviously easy to
also also if you think about I think I
think of it as an Oracle for instance
you can use the grammar to check whether
outputs are valid for instance there's
so so we it's it's amazing that we as
well we love them computer scientists
love grammars we do if you do one year
of if you one year of studying computer
science you know you learn a bit about
grammars and formal languages okay and
you need them later too but but but but
bringing these things together here's my
program and here's the language okay
this so far we've only seen this from
the prospect of creating a specification
and then implementing it and creating a
parser automatically from a firm erm
from a written specification yes we know
that this is a parser generator but the
other way around this is some other way
around here's a program what's its input
that's it that's a problem that has
never been addressed before and I'm not
even sure whether the program has been
posed before and I think the problem has
not been posed before because so far
even though the even though the answer
is all relatively simple it simply was
not obvious how to do that thing is if
you apply standard static symbolic
techniques and have a parse that you
have a parser and you want to find out
what it does using standard static
symbolic techniques you have a looked at
the generative parser with its tables
and everything
it's impossible to impossible to
understand what it does and also for a
constraint solver it's impossible
because you if you have a table with ten
thousand entries you're going to end up
with a constraint that has ten thousand
entry student the solution is lo and
behold the grammar so there was it was
no such thing and only with only by
using a dynamic technique I think by
looking at what's actually happening
during the execution and combining this
with active learning and testing this is
how we can now know now we have a good
grip on how things on how to tackle that
problem it's still going to be a decade
of research till it all works out and
there's plenty of open but there's
plenty of opportunities so I encourage
you all to I'm happy to encourage you
all to to to try to try things to try
these things out for yourself